beaucoup les chéris quand je suis arrivé
tout à l'heure au sud où j'ai vu qu'il y
avait des gens qui m'attendent et un
petit peu comme à l'époque des gilet
jaune
je crois qu'il ya des sources ils
m'attendent dehors c'est vrai que je
suis fan des forains et j'aimerai
toujours essayé de les défendre
ici dans cette émission j'étais pas du
toko et c'est vrai que j'ai vu que
depuis cet après midi ils étaient devant
le studio et c'est vrai qu'ils font
partie un petit peu des oubliés de la
crise les forains donc je vais aller je
vais aller les voir pour voir quelles
sont leurs demandes on va essayer bien
entendu comme à chaque fois de faire
bouger les choses même si on n'y arrive
pas toujours mais au moins essayer et
c'est vrai que voilà ils sont en
détresse et on va aller les voir tiens
voilà voilà mes amis qui sont là et
c'est vrai que voilà je voulais leur
donner la parole
ça va mais chérie ça va les faire alors
merci d'être là les chirurgiens je
reconnais plein je sais les chéris que
vous êtes en galère et que c'est vrai
qu'on ne parle pas du tout de vous on a
vu ce qu'a dit le président il ya
quelques semaines c'est vrai que vous
les patrons de discothèques aussi on
n'en parle pas du tout les gens dans
l'événementiel on n'en parle pas du tout
et c'est vrai que vous êtes en énorme
galère vous savez que j'ai toujours été
voilà proche des forains qui font vos
qui me font rêver voilà moi ils font
rêver les jeunes font rêver et c'est un
kiff voilà ils nous font kiffer ils nous
font rêver et c'est vrai que vous êtes
un énorme galère avec la crise et c'est
vrai que vous êtes un petit peu laissés
pour compte
j'aimerais savoir qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour vous chers mais si je peux
vous aider si on peut faire passer un
message ce soir en direct si on peut se
faire passer un message après déjà mais
franchement je sais que vous attendez
depuis le début de l'après midi donc
déjà merci à vous j'espère que c'est pas
trop ça pas été trop galère du monde du
moment qu'on parle du monde forain c'est
déjà le principal c'est énorme déjà
qu'on parle de nous déjà c'est déjà bien
on vit une galère depuis six mois on a
été arrêté depuis la mi mars
depuis le 1er mars 2020 et l'état l'état
nous a donné un petit coup non on va pas
dire le contraire l'état nous a donné un
petit coup de main simplement
aujourd'hui à nos micros aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les forains les forains ont
un gros problème de redémarrage l'état
vienne nous donner une peut-être une
date provisoire d'euros démarrage le 9
juin mais ce n'est pas sûr
ce n'est pas si on n'a aucune certitude
on attend des fichiers c'est qu'ils
sortent à une commission
interministérielle est alors
d'aujourd'hui faut savoir que les
préfets peuvent nous interdire et les
maires nous interdisent nos fêtes
foraine alors on peut plus tourner les
familles de forains ne peuvent plus
tourner c'est dramatique pour les procès
c'est une catastrophe
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous voyez
qu'on fasse passer comme message vous
est ce que le 9 juin
c'est une date qui vous voit oui pour
l'instant avait il a été demandé aussi
le 19 mai mais c'est peu importe si on a
le 9 juin déjà ça serait déjà rassurant
le 9 juin avec eux avec un taux comme
une rue piétonne une rue de chalandise
si tu préfères et qu'on arrive à essayer
de de pouvoir travailler correctement
sans georges aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on
vous a donné la date du 9 juin
pour l'instant c'est une date mais il y
aura rien nature est pour l'instant
d'accord donc vous voudriez que cette
date en tout cas que vous ayez une date
sûre assez rapide ou fin mai ou début
juin mais pas au delà parce qu'après
c'est vrai que s'arrête la presse à la
galère cette ode à il faut que vous
fassiez le plein en jouant en juillet et
en août on comprend bien c'est là c'est
les gros mois pour les forains septembre
aussi si vous commencez pas à travailler
en mai ou en juin ça va être compliqué
déjà que vous avez pris énormément de
retard je sais c est ça va être
compliqué donc moi si je peux essayer de
faire passer le message
j'espère qu'à des gens qui nous
regardent ce soit si on peut essayer de
faire passer le message voilà via le
vient d'aider des gens qui nous
regardent ou via le gouvernement on
essaiera de passer des coups de fil et
essayer de voir ce qu'on peut faire
je vous le dis c'est vrai qu'à plein il
ya beaucoup de coups durs d'ailleurs on
va faire une émission très vite un avant
la semaine prochaine
surtout les oubliés de la crise tout ce
dont on parle pas tous ceux qui sont en
galère comme les forages uni comme les
patrons de discothèques comme les gens
qui sont dans l'événementiel on a eu
aussi une esthéticienne aussi la
dernière fois inquiété en énorme galère
il y en a plein qui ont été oubliés dans
cette crise on va essayer de faire
bouger les choses
moi je voulais juste avoir votre
sentiment ce soir et savoir ce qu'on
pouvait faire pour vous on va essayer
d'avoir des réponses assez rapide
pouvoir voulait donner assez rapidement
dès demain et essayer d'avancer pour
vous pour que vous soyez plus sécure
mais je vois pas pourquoi vous pourriez
pas ouvrir en début juin où enfin mais
je ne vois pas ce qui empêcherait alors
pour l'instant et on nous parle du neuf
et j'espère que les maires vont jouer le
jeu parce qu'il faut savoir on a arrêté
aussi avec les maires certains maires
ont supprimé leurs fêtes foraines comme
à toulouse il ya des formats qui
manifestent à toulouse à l'heure
actuelle la pour pouvoir exercer leur
métier parce que le maire à supprimer
complètement la fête
ils veulent plus de fête foraine en
france encore faut pas oublier qu'on
fait partie quand même d'une culture
d'une culture populaire et je sais que
toi tu es populaire magnifique si vous
faites moi je vous dis moi ça - larmes -
ccsa fait et moi même maison
je vous dise vouloir monter voilà
aujourd'hui où leur manquer mon arrêt on
à doha une vraie fête foraine et je suis
sûr qu'il ya plein de familles qui nous
regardent et aujourd'hui on a envie
aussi on a besoin de se distraire
on a vécu et on a tous vécu une crise
incroyable et on a besoin de sortir on a
besoin de se distraire ça fait partie
des dix crasse des distractions en
famille on va voir ce qu'on peut faire
je vais essayer d'avancer très vite et
c'est vrai qu'après vous avez dit au
delà de ça c'est au niveau de chaque
mairie qui va falloir bouger donc les
faudra nous tenir au courant voilà de ce
qui se passe dans telle ou telle ville
de france mais on va essayer de faire le
maximum je vous dis pas qu'on va réussir
mais on va essayer de faire le max pour
vous est de faire bouger les choses
comme pour les discothèques aussi je
sais qu'ils sont vraiment galère totale
tiens voilà ah bah tiens mais
apparemment il a rouvert merci merci je
me lève sort merci on vous oublie pas et
je vous donne des nouvelles de marques
d'accor glamour dit à mon frère on s'est
lâché son numéro tout ça merci mon chéri
d'amande merci